[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes and I'm joined by
my co-host Dr Greg Sadler and today
we're talking about Justice fairness and
anger and I understand that you have a
little story or a vignette here about
what got you wanting to do a show
episode specifically about this so why
don't why don't you tell us
what your thoughts were about that yeah
um I was speaking to a friend of mine
um who's a psychologist and he had this
kind of this idea
um that I'm all anger uh stemmed from a
sense of unfairness and so yeah this is
like started to get the gears rolling so
it's is all anger actually from
unfairness is there
um a Justice is Justice always Fair are
there different ideas of justice and
then um but this is the question here's
like here's the rub is that what one
person thinks is fair or just may not be
the same for another person and
um Justice is often summed up
um as giving each person what he or she
is deserves but you know same issue same
rub you know what each person deserves
may change due to the framework of
Justice one uses so is there any like
essential Justice out there
um that we can all go like point to is
like oh yes that that is definitely
Justice or is there uh is it all just
subjective or can we make some like
actual movement towards this uh this
goal I was kind of laughing because as
you were saying that I was thinking to
myself there's some people that are
never going to be satisfied no matter
what you do it's never enough for them
and it could be from you know kind of
narcissism or they're just greedy or
something like that and typically those
people I mean sometimes they'll say yes
I'm doing the wrong thing and I know
that's the case but I don't care but a
lot of times they they have the view
that their point of view is the right
one and everybody else are a bunch of
suckers or they give in too easily you
know and so yeah you're right the the
what what actually is just you you know
we'll talk about this a bit there are
some people who think that there is some
you know standard out there
not necessarily in our world but at
least somewhere that we can access but
the trouble is even if there is
something like that there's there's
always going to be some people that you
could almost like turn their head
towards it and they'd close their eyes
right so I was laughing at that that
sort of image
it's one of the main things as we as
humans have to try to live in these
social structures that we create for
each other and we have to try to somehow
live with each other and we have to at
least tell ourselves that we have some
idea of Justice
okay the question is uh how much of this
is just a you know a social construct
um and how much of this can you convince
other people to go along with
you mean in the sense of like maybe it's
things aren't really just but you manage
to convince people or use rhetoric to
persuade people that
something is just and then then they'll
they'll honor that they'll respect that
they'll they'll stick with that I mean I
think that is an idea that's been around
for a very long time yeah yeah that's
kind of what I'm getting at is like can
can we agree
um
because if we at least agree then we can
move forward based on the agreement
well at least at least so long as people
are willing to honor the agreement
because I think we've all had the
experience of thinking that we're you
know we a consensus has been attained
and then somebody comes back and it
turns out that they they see things very
differently than that we do you know or
if you think about legal matters
um oftentimes we have to go to court
about you know agreements or contracts
or
um I'm forgetting the name terms of
service right for internet things
um because even though it's down there
in literal black and white uh words that
we've all like you know clicked or said
yes I we signed on some line people will
come back and they'll be like what does
is mean here you know
okay Clinton
[Laughter]
um but yeah this is one of the problems
of us using our human language which has
multiple meanings for each individual
word as well as the way that we
construct sentences or yeah you know
there are certain languages that only
mean one thing the problem is they're
usually computer languages and so
they're
unambiguous you know but that's not how
humans work in an unambiguous this is
like totally off topic here but
um there was this thing back in the
early 20th century and it kind of comes
out of the 19th century and this
dream of having a logically perfect
language which is how Ludwig wittenstein
expressed the concept and it was called
the logisis project and you know people
like Bertrand Russell were particularly
important in it and Russell had this
book the philosophy of logical atomism
that I think is probably one of the best
expressions of this ideal and his his
dream was essentially and it was nothing
other than a dream
to take language and then logically
analyze it down to like the Bare Bones
and that would be the stuff that would
be completely as we say univocal where a
term only has one meaning and that
meaning is fixed doesn't change from
Context to context and then you like
rebuild everything back up to the level
where like you and I are right now
talking in normal human language not
Uber nerds speak and it was a complete
failure
because at least I would assume that
it took you know a teenager speaking
this for about five minutes before they
decided to throw some new slang in there
yeah you know I hadn't even thought of
that
um but that would be one there'd be so
many things that could defeat this right
um and and teenagers and the coining of
neologisms that we call slang that would
be a perfect example you don't even have
to like make new words you can just take
the words that you've already got and
give them a slightly different meaning
like think about how cringe has entered
our vocabulary in the last what maybe 15
years or so and now cringe is a mood and
mood doesn't mean mood necessarily it
means something different and which is
similar to Vibe but you know if you ask
people what the hell is what is all this
stuff they can't always give you
definitions of it well that would really
that would be be very botherful for the
Russell of that time and also the the
wickenstein of the the tractatus era
where it was the same idea you know we
can like we can get to a point where
everything is clear and uh they're sort
of like you know in comedy you have the
straight man who doesn't make jokes but
is the butt of jokes the logistics
project was great for making
philosophers the butt of philosophical
jokes
yeah it's
now of course we're also oh go ahead I
was just gonna say it's also kind of
like uh kills
art that uses words uh you know any
poetry is is going to be Con in credibly
hampered by this constraint of being
perfectly clear even things that are
less metaphorical like creative
non-fiction or just you know plain old
essays would be
done in by that you know they and they
wouldn't be that enjoyable
um I mean
we should get back to the topic of
justice and stuff like that but this is
kind of a fascinating topic you know
right
um for the PBA topic for another time
yeah I'll just say this for the people
that are okay into that sort of thing
it's fascinating for them it's enjoyable
for them
but they they seem like almost tone deaf
they don't realize that it makes it
flattens out everything else for
everybody else and it makes them rather
unpopular
[Laughter]
all right so um we've got a number of
different
um thinkers that are different ideas of
Justice throughout the ages
um we're going to touch upon a couple of
them so we start off with Plato
yeah so Plato actually has a whole bunch
of different ideas thrown into his
dialogues at different points and put
into the mouth of different people so
these are not all Plato endorsing that
he's not you know schizophrenic in the
sense of like holding a whole bunch of
different uh ideas in his head that are
that are mutually contradictory but they
they are pretty cool to think through
and you know the Republic is probably
the most important dialogue it's because
it's about Justice and Socrates
um has this uh set of discussions with
these younger men where
um they put forth some ideas and one of
the very common sensical idea I think it
kind of goes to this thing that you were
talking about before Justice is giving
people their due this guy polamarcus
says
um Justice is doing good to good people
and doing bad to bad bad people so yeah
it kind of makes sense right bad people
deserve bad things good people deserve
good things he also frames it in terms
specifically of doing good to friends
and doing bad to enemies but we could
generalize it
a bit more and just say good people in
general and bad people in general and it
sounds good but it is as Socrates shows
us it breaks down very quickly because
there's a number of different problems
probably the most damning one as well
how do we actually know who the good and
bad people are we're often mixed up
about that we rely upon a friend who
turns out to
betray us and are you know are they a
friend no they're not a friend anymore
they're a bad person and what they
deserve is something bad in return
um but you know things aren't always
quite so cut and dry is that there's
people who are kind of in between and
you know sometimes they're good and
sometimes they're bad what do we do with
them so I think that's a
a and another caveat is like okay if if
I consider myself and my friends to be
good but I have this enemy over there
they probably think that they're them
and themselves and their friends are all
good and that I'm the enemy and I'm bad
and so how does one determine
um one is good or bad especially in a
much more gray world yeah I mean that
one doesn't necessarily constitute a
a um throw it out kind of damning
conclusion in part because you can say
Well they're so their enemies over there
they're friends with their friends but
they view you as an enemy therefore is
bad they're going to behave badly
towards you you think that you're good
but you also see them as bad so you you
know you just get a cycle of going doing
bad stuff to each other right and that's
that's actually kind of sustainable
if you think about
um cultures or organizations that have
these rivalries that go on for
Generations you know
that that could actually work it's not
intellectually coherent or morally
coherent but but it it's it's workable
right well it's coherent within your own
tribe yeah but if you're trying to make
that a baseline idea then now you have
the same criteria resulting in different
outcomes
somebody else coming in from the outside
Who belongs to neither of these two
groups that view their in their in-group
is friends and the out group is enemies
would look at that and be like you're
all screwed you know right I mean that's
sort of like the the plot of so many
Star Trek episodes isn't it
yeah they show up there's two groups of
people that are fighting over something
it turns out to be complete BS what
they're fighting over stemming from
something that happened like 30
Generations ago
we are unfortunately tribalistic
creatures well and I think that that
theory of Justice it it um responds to
that fact that we are tribalistic
creatures so maybe that is a place where
a lot of people do start
and like you know as you said it is
sustainable at least very least in the
short term and it suddenly and it
creates a cohesiveness in a group if you
have a orientation against an out group
um but it's not really right sustainable
if you're thinking about the well-being
um of all people
you know and it's interesting too when
you think about it in terms of in in
groups and out groups because a lot of
the moral progress that we've made in
the 21st century in the 20th century in
the 19th century is widening the scope
of who gets to count as
being part of our society and some
people see that as a weakness right
there's there's a lot of proposals oh we
need to purify things uh go back to the
America that we knew in the past which
is you know an illusory uh made up thing
um but
yeah I mean if you think about
Multicultural societies this
um conception of justice is just not
going to work for those very well and
that's what we live in you know
and we're living in a multicultural
Justice in which at least portions of
the populists are still living in a very
tribalistic center for their ideas of
justice and who should
be deserving of uh you know goods and
accolades and who should be you know not
or even who uh should be treated as
enemies within the very Society you know
so this is a good transition to talk
about another theory that comes up again
not one that Plato's endorsing but one
that he thinks is really important to
consider and there's two characters in
particular who articulate this one is
calacles in the gorgeous and the other
is through simicus who's probably a
little bit more famous and maybe
familiar to people the young sophist in
the beginning of the Republic who claims
that Justice is the interest or the
advantage of the stronger so this is
what we often call a might makes Right
theory where Justice is just what the
powerful claim it to be or decided to be
and and it's you know through simicus
um kind of exemplifies this he's trying
to get everybody to pay him for telling
them what Justice is he yells at
Socrates he insults him but after a
while he calms down and and it it turns
out this doesn't work very well and
there's you know I think you could see
some of the problems with it just on its
face there's that relativistic problem
of well
which powerful person this one over here
or this one over here what do you do
when they disagree with each other you
know
it's the problem of tyrants it's like
once you have a powerful leader that is
it is uh in himself making
bad decisions that are going to
specifically harm the people that uh
they are supposed to be ruling then uh
what how is this just you know just
because he can come in and murder you
it's like oh well I'm not going to
murder you today
yeah and that's that's a good point it
makes it it brings out that what we're
talking about here maybe isn't Justice
it's just force or fear and
um
it's a mistake to call that Justice and
you can say well why do they why do they
want to call it justice they're clearly
getting something out of that like it
makes them feel better about themselves
or
it's a way of controlling people you
know like if I go after you and
um I take your stuff like you know kick
in your door and I take your stuff and
you try to uh intervene and I hit you
with a stick or something like that
um
if if I then add insult to injury by
saying what I'm doing is perfectly just
you're going to be like you're full of
crap man uh but if I have the coercive
power of the state you know and
um we could call it the rhetorical power
of custom or something like that what
people are used to on my side a lot of
people might be like yeah man uh you
should have known better than the clash
with the powers that be uh clearly you
got what's coming to you
um is I think this is a common dynamic
if only you didn't resist
yeah
yeah and this isn't just about like say
you know police or stuff like that we
see this happening in academic
institutions we see this happening
um in in sexual politics when people say
oh well you know you shouldn't have
dressed that way if you didn't want to
get uh harassed or you know things like
that
yeah
and
I think one of the main reasons why this
really kind of grades on us is that it
usually results in a reduction of our
autonomy
um that
um you know there's no if you're going
to try to make a society or a government
that is based on an idea of Might makes
right
um then it's not going to be beneficial
for like the flar the flourishing of
individual humans right you know except
for like the one guy who can do it and
it and you know because we're also a
social species we can like oh get a
whole bunch of this one guy going around
being uh you know
bad to people then you get a whole bunch
of group together and you go okay well
now I've got more people I've got more
might and we've you know get rid of you
um and it just it turns us into a
potential
um reoccurring violence a cycle of
violence yeah and and you know that goes
back to that thing that you're pointing
out about
um anger
people when all you really have to keep
people in line is force and you lack
a perception of legitimacy
um that makes people angry when when
force is used on them they're like this
is this is BS this is arbitrary this is
unfair
um and sooner or later I mean
nowadays coercive
societies can be very coercive because
they have lots and lots of tools you
know
um the panopticon yeah technology that
makes it it possible to keep people in
line but we see this over and over again
um even in very repressive societies
people at some point are like this is
this is enough I'm done with this
so and it's often anger that's
barking that initial resistance
yeah yeah look at like the
um the Arab Spring and what was that
like 20
11 or was it later than that 2016 maybe
uh no I want to say the early 20
um
teams tense yeah yeah 20 times yeah
that's
no that's not the odds it's the teens
yeah I mean uh oh go ahead oh please
well I was going to say another thing
that
um because we're spending a lot of time
on the Republic here that Plato has some
of the smarter guys talk about is
justice as I mean you mentioned I don't
remember the exact word that you used
was it social convention or
uh social construct social construct
yeah so that idea was already around
back in Plato's time and glauken and
adamantis who by the way are Plato's
Brothers
um he writes his own Brothers into this
this story they say well you know we
don't actually believe what through
simicus says but Socrates you didn't
knock his argument down we're going to
present you with a better argument we
want to see how you do with this and
they they say that um Justice is
essentially
it's kind of a fraud it's it's a middle
point between doing Injustice and
suffering Injustice so we all agree we
don't want to like we all want to do the
wrong thing we all want to be unfair to
advantage ourselves but because we don't
want other people doing that to us we
say let's all be nice and so we'll all
be just and none of us really wants to
be just but we follow the rules so that
we don't get ourselves into trouble with
our neighbors and you know some of the
stuff that glaucon and adamantis point
out in their time I think is very true
in our time they're like what is it that
parents uh and no not all parents but
what is it that parents say when they
want their kids to be just they like
point at the fact that you don't want to
be ostracized you want to get get along
in society you want to be successful and
you can't do that without getting along
with other people and that
following these these basic rules that
otherwise you would you would feel free
to to violate right so they say nobody
actually Praises Justice for its own
sake everybody Praises justice as
something that will get you what it is
that you want and and they're saying
this because they they don't believe it
themselves but they want to see what
sort of arguments can be brought out
against this and Socrates doesn't
provide them with like a well here's why
it's wrong he like then goes into this
big long discussion of what an ideal
city is like and how it's like the soul
and all of this stuff so the challenge
isn't completely met uh right off the
bat
right and so now we if we kind of go
into his his discussion of the kind of
the tripartite Soul
um that he he Associates with different
portions of the city with the and what
area ruling faculty as your leaders your
um Merchants as the um
appetite yeah and uh the spirit has your
your military that's the other your
portion of that as part of your you know
has your rascibility your anger or your
source of anger
um and that uh to describe it as a
charioteer with your spirit and appetite
as to
horses and you sitting upon the Chariot
as reason to control these two you know
emotional appetites
um are uh
you're right two different metaphors one
coming from the Republic one coming from
the phaedrus the charioteers from the
the phaedrus but they both have the same
elements to them
three parts one of which is reason one
of which is this uh you know irascible
part the part that gives us energy the
part that's concerned with honor and
then all these base desires you know for
wealth and pleasure and stuff like that
yeah
um in that if you want these things as
you know he's kind of talking about from
uh glaucon and his other brother
um that uh that these are kind of he's
not refuting that in this regard he's
saying like okay here's here's what you
want like you're trying to you know use
reason to control your spirit and
appetite
um because it wants things how do you
actually get those in a proper way when
you're living as a social creature in a
society
um you can't go around just like beating
up people to get what you want it's
going through backfire on you yeah one
of the things I actually like about
Plato's account is that
you know an experience that many of us
have is that we can use reason
instrumentally like we have a desire for
something right and we're like how do I
get this thing that I want and so we use
reason in a what we could call a human
way David Hume very famously said reason
is and can only be the slave of the
passions right and so reason doesn't
motivate us sufficiently to do the right
thing even though it tells us what the
right thing to do would be what the just
thing to do or the fair thing to do
would be and even in Plato who's you
know a real rationalist in the sense of
thinking that reason does uh get us in
touch with the good the just the the
beautiful
um reason needs that spirited part of
the Soul as a helper to impose its rule
on the appetites just like the you know
the soldiers help keep order in in the
society Society you know that the
philosopher kings are are telling you
know everybody else what to do
um and so I think that's kind of a cool
idea I mean it's it's something that
that many of us are quite familiar with
just being told what the right thing to
do is and being like yeah yeah I get
that intellectually that's not always
enough for us you know
and and here's
something that you know one of the first
things that we're actually talking about
like anger versus Injustice and that we
have this idea of the tripartite soul of
which the thermos the spirited portion
of it
um is that thing that is that you know
angered so he is making this argument
that
um
that it is necessary for a proper
organization of the human as well as the
city in order to
um be in touch with this anger and uh in
part because you're using that as a
um
response to what you might see is
Injustice so you're using a reason to
Define that and applying that anger in a
proper way that's it it can't just be
like anger for the sake of anger or
being a tough guy or something like that
because one of the things that could go
wrong is that spirited part of the Soul
could like get orders from reason and
say screw you I I've got the power now
I'm doing what I want to do you know so
yeah I mean that's that's essentially
how
um Plato depicts some of the very
war-like Societies in ancient Greece
like the uh the Spartans although he
does also say that the Spartans have
become corrupt because they're seeking
out wealth and stuff like that as well
in book eight of the Republic there is
one other thing from Plato though that I
think is really
um helpful to keep in mind you know
those who are listening when you hear
Plato one of the things that I think
probably comes up first is this notion
of platonic form right that you've got
like the perfect
um original and then everything else is
copies of that and Plato really does
think that with respect to justice so
there is like a perfect form of Justice
now where does it live there's a whole
story about that that we don't have to
go into Plato has like a world of this
but he doesn't adequately explain how
the hell that works
um but the thing that I think that that
is right about this he says every
instance of justice that we see in the
world or we experience or we enact is
only partly just it's not perfectly just
there is no such thing as perfect
Justice here in this realm for us
you can look at something that is in
fact adjust action and you change the
perspective slightly and it looks unjust
because it's not wholly just there is
some injustice in Justice in the way
that that we experience it and you know
I think keeping this in mind would help
so many people out because there's this
tendency to think that like we somehow
are different than everybody else
throughout history and when we do our
just fair right action there's nothing
bad about it whatsoever and it's perfect
and everybody should recognize that then
we get all pissed off when people are
like hey you you left out this thing
over here right
um
you know it's
it's the you know you know was it Maya
Angelou has the the quote of like um uh
do your best and tell you know better
and then do better
um you know or if you just want to look
through the the long history of uh
us as a human species making decisions
which you know we thought were you know
you go back 100 years and you you uh
think that a certain set of norms are
totally great yeah
and now we will look at these things as
like really anathema you go back a
couple hundred years and like you know
slavery is super widespread and all
these things and that we've we've tried
to Tamp down in our modern era but you
know we look at them it's like oh yeah
they're like this is right and proper
that these people aren't actually fully
people and it's totally cool to do that
and like we'd be like what are you
thinking about
how are you even thinking this you know
that is actually a great Point
um so in addition to the like error of
thinking that what we like to call
Justice is totally just
I guess there's sort of a corresponding
error of looking at what somebody else
has done some sort of social Arrangement
and thinking that the Injustice there
makes it totally unjust right and so if
we can't encounter complete Justice
within this world we're not going to
encounter complete Injustice it's
diametric opposite anymore there's going
to be some modicum of Justice within it
right
yeah
I like is there is there this quarter
case of like perfect Injustice what
would that even be uh uh I don't know
it's hard to conceptualize that's for
sure yeah right is it like maybe you
could have like a perfect Injustice for
one individual person
um
I don't know I've been thinking of like
kind of like the idea of um I think it's
uh Ursula Le guin's book those who walk
away from Omaha right right yeah oh
they've got this perfect Society short
story a perfect Society but for some
reason their society required that they
um basically torture a child in a
basement
um all the time a child who is
um
unable to understand the reason behind
it too I think that's that's a key part
of the the story so it's not like you or
I could be like yes I will take on the
heroic sacrifice of being tortured for
the greater good you know like uh like
Mr Spock would always have that the the
how does the line go the good of the
many outweighs the good of the one
yeah there are the few oh okay yeah and
so this child is unable to
to agree to that to consent to that
they're just down there in this dreary
little cell
afraid of a mop in a bucket and having a
horrible horrible time and and it sounds
almost like there always has to be a
child
so it's not just this child if this
child dies they need a new one exactly
yeah and actually
you bring up Star Trek but the the
newest season of Brave New worlds
basically did exactly that oh really
they have a whole episode it's basically
those walked away from omolas
so I'm curious
um who said no to it what was it just
the people or well there were there's
like a group of people and then also the
captain eventually finds out and Captain
Pike on okay and and so
it's like this closed off Society they
don't let people know like how exactly
it runs but like it it requires a
spoiler alerts I guess
um you don't even know the name of the
episode
um it requires a a child
brain as the core components of this
giant Machinery that runs there's their
Planet their society and uh
if if they don't have the child's brain
then the Machinery falls apart and the
whole like planet implodes
That's pretty drastic yeah
so that's I mean this is again totally
uh so you might think that somebody in
that society would be like this can only
be a stopgap solution we need to figure
out something else to keep our planet
from exploding so we don't have to keep
on sacrificing child brains you know
this is not like a workable sustainable
solution to things but I guess maybe
they didn't maybe they're like well good
enough you know
um they're like too happy enjoying their
incredibly amazing lives that they're
like
there are some people from the society
who also walk away and they go live in
some really destitute planet
so I don't know it was a little bit on
the nose and like how
black and white but that's kind of the
whole point of that story yeah um but uh
going back to Plato here like you know
we have this idea of justice but any
um representation of justice is going to
be a simulacrum a poor copy
of this kind of ideal of Justice um
yeah but I think we should
move on to Aristotle yeah you know I'm
not a platonist myself so I don't buy
that there are perfect forms of Justice
or goodness or beauty or these things
that he's saying or let alone bed you
know to use another example like the
ideal bed out there
you know I actually I find a little bit
more plausible that there could be ideal
Justice I don't think that there's going
to be a bed that all other beds are
mirror copies of you know
um that that seems a non-starter to me
but yeah so so we can go to to Aristotle
and Aristotle you know he picks up with
some of these themes
um in the The One book of the nick of
McCain ethics that is entirely devoted
to Justice which shows you that
Aristotle thought this is a really
important topic
he begins by saying people get into all
sorts of arguments with each other
because they don't realize that Justice
is what we call an equivocal term
meaning a term with multiple
senses and they don't realize this in
part because the senses are kind of
close to each other
so already we've talked about a number
of different theories or interpretations
or perspectives on Justice here
um Aristotle thinks that this is what
happens to people all of the time and
they're they're kind of talking past
each other in a lot of cases but because
they think they're talking about the
same thing they get ticked off with each
other they're like how can you be so
stupid as to think that this thing is
Justice you know
um
it's you know it's I think this is
something we experience quite often
right
um yes we we see it um
you know
in our politics especially we're talking
about Aristotle anything that deals with
like two or more people is politics
right
um
at our our state and National politics
like what what is the correct
distribution of funds to different
people
um do we want to give more to education
we want to give more to military
spending or you know or whatever student
loans yeah yeah big time yeah right and
uh so how do we actually uh if we don't
have the the same sense of what these
things are we think that one other
person's idea of justice and just like
the allocation of uh goods and services
in our society
um is going to be injust for others
right yeah and and sometimes it takes
experiencing the effects of it or having
familiarity with something to realize
the unfairness of it you know so like
for example
um let's let's take you know laws and
um police and prisons there's this sense
that a lot of people have that you know
we should make prison as harsh and as
um unpleasant and retributive as
possible because those bastards did
crimes and they need to be punished and
suffer for for what they did
and in some cases that you know that
kind of makes sense there there were
some people when I was teaching at
Indiana State Prison which is a Maximum
Security Prison
um so everybody who was in there was in
there for pretty serious crimes with the
exception of the drug offenses right
because because we punished those
unfairly unjustly and in a lot of ways
and there were some prisoners who other
prisoners would like point out and say
you see that guy over there I hope that
guy never gets out because he is
Thoroughly evil and I know I'm a bad
person but that guy scares the crap out
of me and you need to keep him as far
away from other human beings as as
possible so there is some recognition
that maybe with some people things could
be merited but a lot of the things that
the you know people on the outside view
as oh this is the Just Desserts it's not
really just when you when you are
involved with it or experience it seeing
people get inadequate medical care for
example in prisons that's not fair
um that's actually kind of sadistic to
wish that on somebody
um you know the old thing of oh you're
going to get thrown in prison and then
you're going to get raped which often
doesn't happen
um but the thing the idea that we think
oh that's right and proper is yeah so
in the whole idea of this retribute of
Justice it's you know it's just kind of
like an eye for an eye I want I want you
did something that hurts someone and
thus I want to hurt you back and even
for this gentleman that you're talking
about that you know the other prisoners
thought that they don't want him ever
out
um doesn't mean that you have to make
their experience while they are
incarcerated to be hellish you just have
to make sure that they're not
interacting it's like protective for the
rest of the society to make sure that
he's sequestered yeah we also don't need
to go out of your way to make them hurt
it is actually pretty difficult and it
takes a greater toll on the other
prisoners to make the really bad
prisoners life hellish
um it's kind of ineffective and uh
you know there's all sorts of other
things that we could talk about you know
in terms of like the fairness to the
society and I I'm not a you know like
soft on crime kind of uh uh guy myself
but you you look at the ways in which we
punish and the conditions that we make
people live under
um and you know the the authority and
power that we give to prison
administrators and guards who sometimes
are are you know quite unjust themselves
and you know you can see that
real Justice is not taking place within
the criminal justice system a lot of the
time you know
but to people on the outside until they
actually get caught up within it they
might not see that
you know
I reoriented my my way of thinking about
this oh interesting more of a
um I look at as like us you know we as
individual humans we're humans we have
this whole like lives as humans but um
if we're looking at the criminal justice
system it is a a system in which we as
individuals fit
a place in society
and just as you know your carburetor has
a place in a car on if the carburetor
gets all gunked up yeah you don't get
angry at the carburetor yeah fix it and
hit it with the wrench yeah how do you
put it back together you might have to
clean it out or whatnot and you put it
back together or
at the at some point in time you it
can't be fixed and so you it will have
to get a new one
um and I don't I'm not advocating for
the death penalty here but I am
advocating for sequestering of those
people that are not able to be returned
to society
um but also to not actually have to
actively go out and as long as you don't
see them as I need them to feel bad you
can look at them as
things that could be improved to be
replaced and this comes back to our
conversation we had not too long ago
talking about
um why people do things do they do
things because they're bad or evil or
because they think that's the best thing
at the time they thought for the most
part they thought that was the best
thing to do at the time yeah and
that doesn't make any sense for us to uh
punish them when uh
teaching them better would do just
better if not you know Center control
better Seneca talks about that in his
book on anger which is very concerned
with not just anger but Justice and he
he says that I forget exactly how he
puts it but
um we should be oriented much more at
what you've been talking about is like a
rehabilitative approach to things and if
somebody is indeed so far gone that they
can't but be an enemy to all the rest of
humankind then we unfortunately have to
incapacitate them back then that meant
killing them now we can you know lock
people up for years and years and years
right
so and and he said all of that can be
done without this desire for Revenge
you know and I think he's right about
that
um
but coming back to the Aristotle one of
the things that he says that I really
wanted to talk about and maybe kick
around as an idea so when he when we get
Justice wrong it's often because we
rightly
emphasize one aspect of it so one prime
example that he gives in the politics is
all the darks people who are for you
know a elite rule in society
they they realize that people who are
wealthy are making a greater
contribution to the overall Society in
terms of their wealth right they may be
I mean if they do indeed pay more taxes
right in our society not rich people are
getting away without paying taxes but
let's just assume that that's the case
and he says you know the oligarchs who
think that they should get to run things
um they're partly right but partly wrong
they're realizing that you know they are
contributing something to the society
that other people aren't but that
doesn't give them uh the right to
dominate everything other people and he
talks about like the many in this case
think that well we're all free so we
should all be totally equal
and that's right in some contexts right
um you know like we we should all get to
watch the Packers play and none of us
should have a crappy seat behind the uh
pillar so we can't see the game or you
know we should all have equal
opportunity to go do certain things but
it's not completely right you don't want
to say yeah you know uh the person who's
going to operate on me any old guy
walking in off the street should have
the opportunity to like you know cut up
my organs and and stuff right so and and
what what Aristotle says is each of them
they they're partly right they're partly
wrong they they grasp one aspect and
then they turn that into an absolute and
I think that this is the case for so
many things in our society you know
they're it's not just rich and poor or
Rich and and many
um it can be in terms of um
gender it can be in terms of race it can
be in terms of who's suffered
historically and who hasn't it can be
all sorts of differentials where there's
some people who are like you know oh
think about like you know this whole
notion of like rich people being job
creators so they should get to do
whatever the hell they want not pay any
taxes I mean
there's it's not completely unjust it's
not completely off base but it sure as
hell isn't you know the epitome of
justice that a lot of people have made
it into you know yeah and it in that
case it also like totally
alienates the the worker from the oh wow
I mean from there even the concept of
them being laborers
um and that like that it removes the
agency from the laborers it's like oh no
no you don't you just you happen to be
there by the good grace this job Creator
yeah um that you have a job not that
like you have a skill that is necessary
for them to actually you know produce
these Goods that they want our services
that they want to actually sell
um that it
yes that reminds me of something that
Blaise Pascal says in his uh passes when
he's defining what tyranny is I mean we
usually think of tyranny as like one man
rule you know politically and pusk all
says you're tyrannical any time that you
take some legitimate good by which you
sort of stand out and you're trying to
turn that into an absolute like you know
so because you're attractive you should
be given political power or you should
uh enjoy this privilege or because
you're a good speaker you know you
should have the benefits of an
attractive person like having people
desire you or because and we could go on
and on and on there's all these ways in
which we have you know good things about
ourselves and then people turn them into
reasons why they should get more than
everybody else when sometimes the fact
that we have a good thing
means we don't need as much right I mean
if I'm smart enough to like
I don't know figure out complicated
problems maybe I don't need uh people
helping me out as much as some some poor
guy who can't figure out how to get on
the bus you know
so in this kind
of this kind of brought me to like
you're talking about like there's these
two things either
um you know you have uh giving people
like what they they're they're oh and
kind of like oh yeah
meritocracy type thing or also making
sure that everyone has kind of like an
equal given to them or at least yeah on
and and we have roles here John Rawls um
who uh has another theory of justice
justice as fairness and this is both of
these concepts are now smashed together
into kind of um his idea of what it is
to uh create a society that has fairness
and his concept incorporates both a need
that everyone has like a basic need met
to them and they have equal access to
many opportunities especially equal
access to
um running for positions in government
for representation doesn't mean that
they're they are automatically given
these things but they have the ability
to to run for these things as well as
they that people are rewarded for their
work in a very meritocratic sort of
Ideal
um and this is
brought to through at least the thought
experiment of the veil of ignorance yeah
I mean before we go into the veil of
ignorance I will say that one thing I
really really like about rawl's approach
in what he calls the difference
principle so like this is why we can
still pay doctors more than the janitor
is he says that if we're going to have
inequalities then the overall system has
to work out for the benefit of the worst
off
now that's something that we often don't
have in the way that we distribute
benefits and harms to people the kind of
inequalities that we put up with so that
means that you know think about a
hospital who would be um the most
vulnerable well obviously the patients
right but also the uh the people who
don't make much money and are stuck you
know
um say doing janitorial work you know
where they might be having to clean up a
Hazmat stuff
um if the doctor is going to be paid
more that's fine we should pay them more
but it has to work out for the benefit
of all of the most disadvantaged I think
that's that's pretty fair
um it brings us out in the the concept
of maximen and you like and many ways
you try to maximize a certain thing like
yeah and most of our economies you're
trying to maximize the most profit
that's great
um but it might also have some negative
externalities uh in his idea of Maxi men
the society at least a society that
you're trying to maximize for the
minimum and so whatever Society produces
the most for the least of the people in
the society is the society you should go
for so
um he would definitely not create omalos
uh because that that person's doing the
worst right
um but uh so basically it's you might
cut off some of the the peaks of you
know incredible wealth excess but you
make sure that everyone is at least
covered to a minimum yeah
yeah and that's that's something that
has been eroded significantly in In Our
Lifetime in our society and in others I
mean this is something that I think is a
lot of people in Great Britain are very
worried about you know
um but we should we should you mentioned
the veil of ignorance so we should tell
our viewers if they didn't listen to the
episode Way Way Back on thought
experiments where we talked about this
we should tell them what it is now so
the veil of ignorance is a thought
experiment by which on you before you
are born into a society it is a thought
experiment after all on a crate in a
society in which you do not know where
you will be born into it and so the
thought experiment goes if you are to
create a society you would want to
create a society in which if you happen
to draw the Short Straw and get the
worst position in society you would
still have a happy and productive life
yeah so a lot of the inequalities that
we accept as just being part of the way
things are
those would go by the wayside because if
you're rational I mean think about like
gender inequality right so if we as has
been often the case historically if men
are privileged over women you know not
necessarily every single man and every
single woman but on on the aggregate
um but you don't know whether you're
going to be a man or a woman you'd be
stupid to set up a society in which you
might get screwed over you know
yeah so you know once again the uh you
don't know if you're male or female
preacher poor smarter dumb any
particular access that you want to throw
into you could be any of these things
you know one you the smarter dumb thing
brings up a really interesting point
Rawls also says that you can't predict
what sort of like um interests or
psychological proclivities you might
have so you know let's say
you I don't know there's a hobby that
you really can't stand uh in in the
current world and you would you know be
like yeah let's get rid of all those
people who do that thing you know model
train Builders exactly yeah that's a
good one right oh those insufferable
model trainers or whatever they call
themselves I'm sure there's some some
name for it micro Engineers Maybe
you don't know that under the veil of
ignorance you might you might actually
have a
you know whatever we're going to call it
you know an inclination to collecting
and running and chatting about model
trains so you you sure as hell wouldn't
want to make things difficult for model
train enthusiasts
yeah so it's definitely trying to
maximize the freedom for whatever you
want to do yeah I mean you can say this
about like people's
um uh sexual desires so long as they're
you know there'd have to be certain
guardrails I can't be like you know yeah
I'm super into like hurting everybody
all the time okay that wouldn't be one
that you would want in the society but a
lot of things that people consider Kinks
I think Rawls would probably although he
I think was pretty straight lace
especially going by his writing but
probably very dry well you don't want to
rule that sort of thing out or you don't
think about pineapple on Pizza we'll
take something more innocuous that
people get really really upset about
um you wouldn't if you were good rawlsy
and you wouldn't want a world where
pineapple on pizza was ruled out because
maybe you like it and so
one of the big things about this is uh
you know as fairness like we we have a
lot of people that feel like the society
that we built is unfair and they become
angry about this kind of coming back to
our anger ID yeah
um is that too we are working towards
trying to find a better way to deal with
this anger
um and um and if there's a feeling of
Injustice that is one of definitely the
the major ways that this come to you
know that's a really interesting point I
don't recall Rawls
and it's been a while since I've read a
theory of Justice talking about anger or
indignation right but maybe that would
be something that could be
um
brought into his his treatment if you if
you were to like see an injustice and
get angry about it maybe that's
something that under the veil of
ignorance we would rule out
right so
um it's coming to the end of the hour
here so I think we should sign off so
I've got the words of Seneca the younger
Sword of Justice is ill placed in the
hands of an angry man
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]